[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Hello.
I'm Reto Meier for
"The Developer Show."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
We recently pushed
the source code
for the 2018 version of the
Santa Tracker Android app,
including its 17 mini games,
Santa tracking feature,
wear app, and more.
This year included lots
of code improvements
that you can check
out, including
increasing the minimum
SDK version to Lollipop,
migrating from the Support
Library to Android X, reducing
the file sizes of
the game assets
by switching to modern
formats, and much more.
The GitHub link is on the
post linked in the description
below.
Chrome 72 is now
available in beta.
With it, creating public
class fields in JavaScript
is now much cleaner.
You can see the page has been
activated with the new user
activation API, and localizing
lists becomes way easier
with the Intl format API.
More info and example
code are on the post.
Upgraded Places SDKs for Android
and iOS are now available.
They're designed to make it much
easier for you to use and scale
with our rich Places data by
providing the same reliability,
security, and customer support
as our other Google Maps
platform products.
Links to the migration
guides are in the post.
Cloud Firestore, our
server-less, NoSQL document
database is now
generally available.
It's also now available
in 10 new locations
with a significant
price reduction
for regional instances
and integration
with Stackdriver for monitoring.
Lots of detail, screenshots,
and links to get started
are on the post.
Check out this post for the
details you should know about
the sunset of consumer
Google+ on April 2nd.
All Google+ APIs
are shutting down,
including Google+ sign-in
and requests for Google+
[INAUDIBLE] scopes.
The wind-down process
has already begun,
so you may notice intermittent
API failures leading up
to the March 7th deadline.
Kubernetes Operator
for Apache Spark
helps you easily manage your
Spark applications natively
from Kubernetes.
And it's now available in
beta from the GCP Marketplace
for Kubernetes.
Links to the Marketplace and
documentation are on the post.
Link in description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Reto Meier for
"Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
SPEAKER: Let me hear your
best, uh, Santa laugh.
RETO MEIER: My Sa--
Ho, ho, ho!
SPEAKER: Pretty good.
RETO MEIER: Pretty good?
Yeah.
You know, I don't have quite the
belly, but I'm working on it.